et pour débattre de la politique
énergétique de la France de la marge de
manœuvre du gouvernement j'accueille
Cécile Antonin bonjour bonjour Céline
c'est ce que j'ai sur ma fiche bah voilà
c'est le premier petit bug de la de la
de la saison il en faut bien
quelques-uns excusez-moi Céline Antonin
évidemment économise senior le FCE
enseignante à Sciences Po Paris Nicolas
Goldberg bonjour bienvenue vous êtes
expert energy chez Columbus consulting
et responsable énergie au sein du cercle
de réflexion le signe tank Terranova
Erwan Benezet bonjour bienvenue à vous
aussi vous êtes journaliste au service
économie du Parisien Aujourd'hui en
France et auteur de ce livre nucléaire
une catastrophe française qui est
publiée aux éditions Fire et Mathieu
croissanto évidemment il travaille est
politique est resté à mes côtés alors je
vous le disais l'actualité de cette de
cette fin d'après-midi c'est la
conférence de presse du Président de la
République après un échange avec le
chancelier allemand Olaf Scholtz alors
le la déclaration on va dire la plus
marquante d'Emmanuel Macron c'est sans
doute autour de cette idée de
contribution européenne alors évidemment
il n'a pas employé le terme de taxes sur
les super profits est-ce que ça y
ressemble on va d'abord écouter Emmanuel
Macron la France et l'Allemagne ont la
même position nous privilégions en effet
une contribution européenne et notre
souhait est que cela passe par l'Europe
l'Europe ensuite restituera à chaque
nation justement les
les sommes ainsi perçues pour pouvoir
financer les mesures nationales prises
pour accompagner les ménages et les
entreprises et nous partageons et je
crois que c'est la même chose que nous
partageons avec plusieurs autres pays et
dirigeants la même vision des choses en
la matière que c'est plus cohérent que
ça évitera de créer des distorsions
Céline Antonin c'est une taxe peut-être
pas sur les super profits on verra mais
c'est une taxe même si Emmanuel Macron
n'emploie pas le terme oui tout à fait a
priori oui on comprend que l'idée c'est
d'avoir une taxation alors à l'échelle
européenne alors à priori plus on texte
à une grande échelle plus c'était
efficace puisque effectivement ce qu'on
sait c'est que par exemple sur des
grands groupes ce qui se passe c'est que
quand on taxe à l'échelle d'un pays
effectivement c'est des groupes qui
bénéficient notamment du bénéfice
consolidé va mondialiser et on peut
facilement déplacer les sommes qu'on
perçoit en fait d'un pays à un autre
donc a priori plus l'échelle est
importante mieux c'est après et ça
serait encore mieux que ce soit à une
échelle encore supérieure mais pourquoi
pas ce qu'il y a c'est que j'ai
l'impression quand même que certains
pays l'ont déjà fait selon des modalités
parfois assez différentes alors c'est
vrai que déjà il y a une différence
entre les pays qui sont eux-mêmes
producteurs d'énergie ceux qui ne le
sont pas puisque ils ne texte pas de la
même façon donc à mon avis ça va être un
petit peu compliqué d'arriver à un
consensus mais bon pourquoi pas enfin
moi je pense que en tout cas quand on
voit ce que ça peut représenter le fait
de soutenir les ménages dans cette
période pour les finances publiques je
pense que l'idée de répartir la charge
fiscale entre les contribuables les
entreprises etc c'est quand même plutôt
une bonne chose il faut pas que ça
repose uniquement sur sur le creusement
de du déficit et de la dette Nicolas
Goldberg ça peut prendre quelle forme
quelle durée parce que il faut leur
passer par les différentes
phases on va dire de validation des
instances européennes après quand il y a
la volonté politique on peut faire on
peut faire plein de choses la question
c'est plutôt le périmètre est-ce que
vous mettez en place donc sur est-ce que
c'est une taxe ou pas on avait parlé
d'épongé les les surprofis parce que
pour certains libéraux faut pas parler
de taxes donc on dit on éponge les
surprofis puis on réparti après quelques
maigre en plein enfin qu'est-ce qu'on
appelle les surprofis quel est le
périmètre est-ce qu'il y a les
entreprises d'énergie est-ce qu'il y a
les autres
voilà tout ça c'est des questions qui
restent qui restent à résoudre
voilà je je j'en sais pas j'en sais pas
plus pour l'instant il y a eu des taxes
exceptionnels dans dans l'histoire on en
connaît maintenant là il y a la question
du périmètre moi j'entendais ce matin on
disait oui il faut taxer sur profits des
entreprises qui font de l'énergie EDF
c'est pas des surprofis aujourd'hui ils
ont plutôt fait des perdre justement
parce qu'ils ont assumé une partie du
bouclier tarifaire en France via
l'augmentation du du nucléaire régulé et
en plus ils ont de la baisse de
production dont on parlait dans le
reportage avant qui fait qu'ils n'ont
pas de surprofit donc voilà moi j'ai
surtout beaucoup de questions plus que
des que des réponses on verra et vous
Erwan Benezet quand on pense à cette
taxe sur profit spontanément tout le
monde dit total énergie faut pas oublier
que toi tu as l'énergie
offre une ristourne à ses clients depuis
quand même plusieurs mois déjà donc
c'est une façon de redistribuer les
super les surpris en tout cas je
reprends la voilà je reprends la
communication de Total énergie alors pas
seulement la communication totale
énergie euh Nicolas parlait de volonté
politique et je me permettrai d'avoir
d'apporter un petit bémol enfin en tout
cas un petit peu circonspect sur ce
déclaratif d'Emmanuel Macron sortir de
cette visioconférence avec Olaf scholls
j'écoutais ce matin monsieur Lescure le
ministre de l'Industrie qui semblait
plutôt dire ce que vous venez de dire
c'est-à-dire attention les grands
énergéticiens français ont déjà mis la
main à la poche donc ici tu es totale
énergie et la ristourne qui vient d'être
remise en place il est revenu sur EDF et
effectivement avec les 8,3 milliards
d'euros qui lui aura coûté cette énergie
d'origine nucléaire qu'il doit revendre
après cassé à ses concurrents c'est ma
CGM le transporteur qui Frédéric Stone
bref tout ça pour dire que selon lui ces
grandes énergéticiens avaient déjà
contribué qu'il était peut-être pas
évident de leur redemander plus donc il
y a une petite contradiction entre les
uns et les autres je ne suis pas sûr que
la volonté politique justement soit au
rendez-vous
dans l'équation du gouvernement et on va
sortir un peu de la de la conférence de
presse de d'Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui
pour se placer un peu plus effectivement
dans dans la perspective du plan qui est
de sobriété qui doit être annoncé à la
fin du mois dans cette équation il y a
il y a ce chiffre là qui qui claque le
mégawattheure à 1000 € c'était le 26
août il faut savoir que il ne valait que
85 euros il y a un an comment on
explique cette cette hausse vertigineuse
c'est une antenne alors on explique
cette c'est un peu baissé je crois
depuis d'ailleurs
on est à 600 ce qui est quand même
encore
totalement démentiel mais bon mais on
l'a dit enfin vous l'avez dit dans le
sujet précédent on a effectivement des
centrales qui sont en partie à l'arrêt
donc 24 sur 56 donc enfin qui uniquement
qui fonctionne donc c'est c'est à dire
que on a effectivement un déficit à ce
niveau là on a en fait enfin une
problématique qui globale qui est en
plus pas uniquement sur l'électricité on
a le conflit avec la Russie mais on a la
problématique sur pour le gaz aussi qui
dure en fait depuis bien avant la
question de l'Ukraine parce que en
réalité c'est vrai qu'on a tendance à
imputer au conflit alors bien entendu il
y a eu une flambée du prix mais en fait
il y a déjà eu de la part de la Russie
des tentatives d'avoir la main sur le
robinet et de faire un peu plier
l'Europe puisque au moment de la
construction de North stream 2 donc qui
était le gazoduc le nouveau gazoduc qui
devait amener encore plus de gaz vers
l'Europe bah en fait l'Allemagne la
Russie plutôt devait avait la main sur
le robinet donc un moment donné a voulu
un petit peu montrer que nous étions en
position de faiblesse et donc c'est à ce
moment-là que le prix du gaz avait
commencé à fondre flamber et que ça a
continué mais en tout cas sur la
question sur la question des centrales
clairement on voit bien qu'on a alors on
a un ordre d'appel en plus de pour
produire de l'électricité donc
effectivement on a un ordre d'appel des
centrales de production d'électricité
donc on a le charbon là houille on a le
gaz naturel on a les les enfin voilà les
énergies fossiles disons et
effectivement comme on a tous qui
augmente de tout du charbon de du gaz ça
se répercute sur le prix d'électricité
donc c'est concomitant disons que le
comportement là des marchés aujourd'hui
Nicolas en parlera même certainement
encore mieux que moi mais complètement
erratique irrationnel en fait il réagit
à la moindre annonce c'était concomitant
avec le l'annonce du prolongement de
l'arrêt de 4 réacteurs nucléaires parmi
les 12 qui a provoqué le pic à Lyon à
1000 euros pour corrosion et là le le
marché se sont complètement emballés ils
sont est devenu extrêmement sensibles et
on est monté effectivement à un pic
au-delà de 1000 euros le mégawattheure
et là donc vous nous le disiez c'est
redescendu autour de 600 ce qui reste
quand même totalement totalement dingue
mais est-ce que on ne doit pas quand
même se préparer à vivre durablement
avec une électricité chère surtout que
enfin voilà il y a des choix qui ont été
faits d'électrification massive de de
notre quotidien de notre société et
notamment de nos mobilités donc
l'électricité elle va être toujours plus
demandée dans les dans les décennies
dans les années les décennies à venir
oui mais ensuite ça dépend qu'est-ce
qu'on appelle durablement cher là
aujourd'hui vous êtes dans un système de
gestion de la pénurie on n'est plus dans
une économie de marché normale parce que
si on était dans une économie de marché
normale il faut bien dire à tout le
monde ce que c'est que 600 euros ou 1000
euros du mégawattheure le mégawater qui
va sortir des réacteurs nucléaires de
inkipoint en construction au Royaume-Uni
c'est 80 12 pounds plus ou moins 92
euros si vous voulez on disait déjà que
c'était extrêmement cher par rapport au
prix de marché donc quand vous avez un
prix de marché autour de
600000 euros on voit bien que c'est un
prix qui est démentiel
parce que cette pénurie qu'on a
aujourd'hui elle est réelle et quand EDF
effectivement nous dit nous dit bah en
fait il y a 2 gigawatts de nucléaire que
je vais arrêter un petit peu plus
longtemps vous avez des acteurs qui vous
disent ah ben attendez moi j'avais prévu
d'acheter cette électricité qui
sortirait de ces centrales nucléaires là
vous me dit qu'elles sont pas là donc je
dois racheter sur les marchés c'est ce
qui fait que j'ai un phénomène où il y a
beaucoup d'acteurs qui achètent très
vite parce qu'il y a un effet il y a un
effet panique ça ça joue à la hausse
puis après ça se calme un peu ça
redescend à 600 qui est beaucoup trop
haut mais ce prix de 600 euros vous le
retrouvez sur les prix de 2024 et 2025
ce qui vous montre qu'effectivement sur
les deux trois ans à venir on va avoir
un problème parce qu'on a un déficit de
production pour autant est-ce que c'est
inévitable d'avoir un déficit de
production comme ça sur le long très
long terme alors que l'électricité je
rappelle quand même que c'est un bien de
première nécessité et ça va être un bien
clé de la décarbonation maintenant après
il y a des choix politiques il y a des
architectures de marché qui se décident
le marché de l'électricité ça n'a pas
toujours existé c'est une construction
donc on peut dire qu'on investit
différemment qu'on répartit les coûts
différemment au sein au sein de la
population un prix un coup c'est pas
pareil effectivement la transition ça va
coûter cher la non transition coûte
encore plus cher après ça dépend de
comment est-ce que vous répartissez les
coûts entre les investisseurs les
consommateurs Mathieu Ollier intervenir
j'entendais dans le sujet d'ouverture du
débat que les réacteurs seraient remis
service on va le moment cet hiver c'est
ça je rappelle le chiffre vous l'avez
donné tout à l'heure il y a 32 réacteurs
à l'arrêt 24 qui fonctionnent
vont se remettre à produire est-ce que
ça va faire chuter les prix non mais
Nicolas Goldberg et ensuite Erwan dans
cet alors rapidement alors oui et non
parce que déjà est-ce qu'ils vont tous
revenir il faudra voir en février où
est-ce que où est-ce qu'on en est
ensuite quand il reviendront tous mais
ça suffit pas ça suffit pas d'avoir
seulement enfin on a cinq ans si
réacteurs nucléaires même si on a tous
les réacteurs nucléaires qui
fonctionnent on n'a pas assez d'énergie
bas carbone parce qu'il faut rappeler
qu'on utilise deux tiers d'énergie
fossile dans notre consommation finale
d'énergie et que il y a toujours du gaz
pour produire de l'électricité donc si
on ajoute l'électrification des usages
le fait que il reviendront peut-être
mais ce sera temporaire enfin se dire
les réacteurs nucléaires il faut les
arrêter il y a encore des visites
décennales à faire c'est pas ça qui va
durablement faire baisser les prix on
aura besoin d'autre chose plus de moyens
de production et plus de contrôle
que vous avez publié ce livre nucléaire
une catastrophe euh française déjà pour
répondre à la question de Mathieu est-ce
que c'est possible de de tous les les
remettre en service quand on quand on
voit les les difficultés de maintenance
de corrosion de de d'embauche tout
simplement trouver du personnel qualifié
pour intervenir auquel les centrales
français sont confrontés aujourd'hui
avant de vous apporter vraiment la
réponse à cette question je vais d'abord
essayer d'expliquer pourquoi on se pose
la question parce que on parlait des
1000 euros le mégawattheure et puis on
est revenu à 600 qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé entre les deux la le la
communication du gouvernement est à un
petit peu été modifié on se souvient
d'un Espagnol une hachée qui au sortir
de du Conseil de défense explique que
finalement effectivement d'ici la fin de
l'hiver les réacteurs seraient remis en
fonctionnement en espagnol
n'est pas EDF n'est pas l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire en tout cas elle met la
pression sur EDF pour que tout soit fait
et les marchés se calment le signal à ce
moment-là il était pas envoyé aux
consommateur à qui on arrête pas de dire
qu'il va falloir se serrer la voiture
etc il était envoyé au marché c'est pour
ça que tout à l'heure je parlais un
petit peu d'irrationalité des marchés
c'est que le déclaratif fait bouger
maintenant je vais répondre question
est-ce que c'est possible
par contre depuis j'ai effectivement
posé des questions à des experts poser
la question à l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que ça va être très très compliqué
notamment pour une raison déjà très
objective qui est que parmi ces
réacteurs qui devraient être remis en
service et notamment les douze réacteurs
qui sont pour l'instant arrêté pour les
problèmes de corrosion il y en a dans
tous les examens ne sont pas encore
terminés donc on ne sait pas quel est le
comment dire l'ampleur des dégâts et de
la corrosion on est loin de la
réparation quoi si si l'examen n'est pas
terminé il y a encore il y a encore des
des examens à faire alors pas tous
invasif c'est à dire grâce à une
nouvelle un nouveau une nouvelle
technique d'ultrasons on peut déjà se
faire une idée mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que tous les examens ne sont pas
faits donc il y a le déclaratif de de du
gouvernement du politique et même d'EDF
mais savoir si les 32 réacteurs seront
remis en marche avant la fin de l'hiver
on ne le sait pas d'autant que Echine
j'en finirai là il y a d'autres
réacteurs qui vont être arrêtés pour
maintenant alors ils sont pas arrêtés au
plus fort de l'hiver mais dès la fin de
l'hiver vous avez d'autres réacteurs qui
vont devoir être arrêtés soit pour
changement de combustible soit pour des
visites de de d'entretien ou des visites
des Sénats c'est pour ça que c'est les
prio continueront effectivement voilà
c'était juste pour dire que je pense
qu'on paye aussi les errements
finalement du politique qui a fait des
choix pas clair du tout concernant le
nucléaire enfin je veux dire oui c'est
c'est qu'on a eu pendant un moment il
fallait sortir du nucléaire en tout cas
on nous disait pas la panacée Emmanuel
Macron il commence son premier
quinquennat en fermant
et puis il termine en disant on va créer
une centrale donc on voit bien que le
nucléaire c'est pas un investissement
qui se fait sur trois ans ou 4 ans enfin
je veux dire c'est des visions à long
terme qu'il faut avoir et là je pense
qu'on est on a manqué cruellement de
cette vision d'ailleurs je rappelle que
les hivers précédents on était déjà
parfois à la limite je veux dire le
système électrique on voyait que
une responsabilité du de la part du
patron d'EDF aussi non pas de données
parce que là on blâme les politiques et
c'est vrai que les politiques ont tenues
un discours anti-nucléaire beaucoup mais
personne n'a dit on débranche le
nucléaire en deux jours donc les visites
qui devaient être faites cette année
elles étaient prévues les problèmes ils
auraient pu être anticipés c'est quand
même aussi
le fait qu'on n'ait pas assez
le planning
responsabilité partagée parce que
qu'est-ce qui quand on a lancé flamant
ville le père de flamants ville on a dit
construction en 5 ans 3 milliards
d'euros on aura respecté ce calendrier
là je pense qu'on en aura élancé 40
derrière c'est pas ce qui s'est c'est
pas ce qui s'est passé flamant vide
n'est toujours pas en service 14 15 ans
après le début du après le début du
chantier donc c'est aussi ça qui a
entraîné des airements dans la politique
énergétique donc c'est ça aussi qui a
fait qu'on n'a pas lancé plus de pairs
c'est pas l'argent politique engouffrer
dans le père de Flamanville on n'a pas
pu le placer ailleurs non je suis en
train je suis en train de vous dire
quand si je vais vous voir je vous dire
je vais réparer votre maison ok vous me
dites ça tombe bien parce que j'ai plein
d'autres chantiers à faire bon je prends
15 ans de retard je multiplie la facture
par 4 est-ce que vous me donnez les
autres chantiers peut-être pas c'est pas
je vais réfléchir c'est vraiment pas sûr
que vous allez faire ça donc voilà c'est
aussi ça qui fait qu'on qu'on attardé
enfin sous l'air Sarkozy on voulait on
voulait pas lancer un EP en voulant le
C2 autres il y avait le père de Pandi on
s'est dit bah voilà ce sera un autre
père il veut un débat sur le troisième
et enfin sur le fait qu'on soit au plus
juste en ce moment ces hivers là c'était
prévu depuis un moment on savait que il
allait avoir un pic de visite décennale
un pic d'arrêt pour prolonger le parc
nucléaire on pensait que c'était quatre
mois EDF nous dit nous dit plutôt 6 et
ensuite les corrosion bah ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on a qu'on a pas prévu
donc voilà quand on dit responsabilité
état EDF moi je pense qu'il y a une
responsabilité partager il y a eu des
errements mais certes Flamanville aucune
loto l'opéra c'était pas non plus une
grande réussite industrielle pour pas
dire que c'était un échec et là je parle
bien compliqué en grand nombre donc en
fait c'est ça aussi qui a fait alors pas
relancer et que je vais vous donner la
parole il y a une journaliste au sein de
la rédaction de Public Sénat qui connaît
bien cette question du nucléaire c'est
Marion Vigo elle avait déjà signé un
premier documentaire et elle en a un
second en préparation qui sera diffusé
dans dans quelques dans quelques jours
et dans le cadre de ce second
documentaire elle a rencontré Bernard de
rotsuk qui est le président de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire il
réclame un plan Marshall écoutez je
choisis volontairement cette expression
parce que dans l'esprit général ça
marque et le plan Marshall dans l'esprit
commun c'est à la fois un plan de
reconquête et un plan de
réindustrialisation et effectivement
pour pouvoir accompagner les projets de
nouveaux nucléaires pour pouvoir
accompagner les travaux importants pour
la poursuite d'exploitation
central mais aussi des installations du
cycle combustible il faudra procéder à
des investissements massifs et il faudra
procéder à une reconquête industrielle
il faut aller beaucoup plus loin ce
n'est pas avec le plan de relance tel
qu'il est prévu mais que les efforts qui
sont prévus par la filière ils vont dans
le bon sens mais ils ne sont pas à
dimension de ce qui est nécessaire pour
avoir à la fois un programme qui soit
robuste réaliste et réalisable
Erwan Benezet un plan Marshall vous avez
certainement pas la réponse à la
question mais ça pourrait se monter à
combien de milliards ou de dizaines de
milliards d'euros vous qui avez enquêté
sur l'état de du parc nucléaire alors ce
que vous donnez deux chiffres qui vont
donner un peu un indice et permettre de
répondre en partie à votre question le
précédent plan Marshall du nucléaire le
plus grand chantier industriel de toute
notre histoire lancée au début des
années 70 nous a coûté près de 200
milliards d'euros actuels 200 milliards
et on pourrait parler pour vous allez me
dire oui mais ça c'était les
aujourd'hui les réacteurs prochains
projets de construction c'est plus de 60
milliards 6 EPR et il y en aura encore 8
autres derrière donc ce que dit
effectivement le président actuel de
l'ASN c'est que si on veut vraiment à
avoir une une volonté politique de
relance de relancer le nucléaire il va
falloir y mettre les moyens et on n'est
pas certain
EDF et même le pouvoir politique n'est
pas toujours été un grand champion pour
dimensionner et anticiper les coûts et
les délais vous parliez de le père de
Flamanville effectivement ces 3,3
milliards à l'époque quand ça a été
lancé ça devait être mis en service en
2012 on est en 2022 ça n'est toujours
pas le cas et pour l'instant ça a coûté
plus de 20 milliards mais pardon je vais
poser une question de béotien j'assume
totalement et est-ce que cette
technologie il faut continuer de visiter
est-ce qu'elle est fiable et est-ce
qu'il y a une alternative est-ce que
vous voyez ce que je veux dire est-ce
qu'on sait faire des centrales
nucléaires autrement en forme c'est une
question de bossien j'assume je vais
donner la mais vous avez raison c'est
une excellente fin je pense que c'est
une très bonne question c'est que c'est
juste que elle peut être fiable mais il
faut y mettre vraiment vraiment les
moyens et le nucléaire actuellement ce
qui est en train de se passer autour de
lui c'est tout ce dont il n'a pas besoin
c'est-à-dire il n'a pas il n'a pas
besoin de pression économique il n'a pas
besoin d'une sous-traitance
exagérée ce qui a été le cas il n'a pas
besoin de resserrer le coup ce qui a été
le cas il a besoin d'être anticipé
d'amont à aval et notamment sur les
déchets sur le démantèlement ce qui
n'est pas le cas et actuellement on en
parle plus du tout mais ce sont les
problèmes du nucléaire actuel et donc il
faudrait déjà résoudre le problème du
terre actuels avant de penser le
nucléaire de demain un mot Nicolas
goldber sur la technologie EPR et puis
ensuite je vous donne la parole en fait
la technologie opère on est un petit peu
obligé de partir dedans parce que sinon
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on va pas prendre
un design russe un design américain ou
un design chinois donc aujourd'hui c'est
ce dont la filière française dispose
donc le père et là on va faire certifier
un nouveau un design qui est celui de
l'EPR 2 il faut quand même bien rappeler
que certifier un design de réacteur
nucléaire ça prend 6 ans et ça c'est
juste pour le certifier après il faut
les études les études techniques
derrière il faut les ingénieurs donc si
on multiplie comme ça les designs est-ce
qu'on risque pas de reproduire les
problèmes qu'on a eu avec le père de
Flamanville c'est une vraie question
donc là en fait construire des opr2
c'est un pari technologique enfin c'est
un pari technique de dire bah voilà on a
fait des erreurs avec le père on
ressertifie un nouveau design
inspiré de l'Opéra 1 pour simplifier et
penser qu'on peut le faire si on le fait
pas derrière ça veut dire qu'on va ne
pas construire de réacteurs nucléaires
en fait c'est d'aller de fait dans une
sortie du nuclé oui parce que au fur et
à mesure que les centrales actuel
vieilliront il faudra bien les fermer et
ça c'est un pari indus c'est un pari
technologique que font certains en
disant on aura des technologies pour
mais est-ce que c'est ce que disait le
rapport de RT c'est quand même incertain
sur le fait de la construire un nouveau
réseau d'hydrogène pour alimenter des
centrales à gaz qu'on aurait des carboné
avec de l'hydrogène pour pallier de
l'intermittence du renouvelable alors
que si on fait suffisamment de nucléaire
on n'a pas besoin de faire ce pari
technologique sur le nucléaire il y a
encore plein de thèmes dans ce débat qui
est passionnant c'est une Antonin ça
change quoi la nationalisation la
renationalisation de DF c'est un atout
pour vous ou pas oui moi enfin moi je
pense que c'est
plus enfin étant donné j'allais dire le
le caractère le côté systémique en plus
d'EDF et puis on voit bien que c'est
quand même l'énergie c'est pas n'importe
quel bien en fait c'est quand même c'est
enfin voilà c'est un bien de base une
consommation je veux dire on peut pas
considérer ça comme un bien de
consommation courante donc j'estime que
dans cette mesure ça me paraît assez
normal je veux dire il y avait des
tarifs réglementés etc donc que ce soit
nationaliser ça ne choque pas d'autant
que je pense qu'on a beaucoup mis
l'accent alors ça c'était dans les
années 2000 sur la question de
finalement de la mise en concurrence des
distributeurs de la distribution sur
l'électricité et on sait pas forcément
beaucoup posé de questions sur
l'investissement à long terme dans le
nucléaire et donc moi je trouve que on
s'est peut-être trop posé ces questions
de concurrence à l'échelle de l'Union
européenne qui sont importantes mais on
a peut-être pas assez vu le côté
d'investissement stratégie qui pourrait
y avoir dans le nucléaire et juste pour
rebondir sur ce qu'on disait le
nucléaire fait partie quand même des
filières d'excellence aussi de la France
il faut quand même le rappeler et à
l'heure où on cherche quand même des
filières aussi d'excellents encore ça
aujourd'hui pour développer notre
industrie
moi je trouve très peut-être je suis
très optimiste mais enfin en tout cas ça
a été
ça a été et c'est vrai qu'on voit que
par exemple il y a des une jeune pousse
donc une une start-up allemande Marvel
fusion qui a qui essaye de créer
justement d'utiliser cette technologie
de la de la de la fusion nucléaire sans
déchets donc on voit qu'il y a quand
même nos concurrents européens essaient
de trouver des moyens de d'aller encore
plus loin donc je trouve que ça serait
dommage d'abandonner cette filière qui
pour nous est quand même a été en tout
cas une filière d'excellence alors on va
élargir un peu et peut-être répondre à
une question que que vous vous posez
parce que vous nous écoutez la débattre
autour de de la stratégie énergétique du
gouvernement mais il y a une vraie
question c'est est-ce qu'il y aura des
coupures cet hiver et si oui sous quelle
forme on va y répondre évidemment et je
voudrais
parler d'un mot qui fait irruption dans
le vocabulaire de nos politiques c'est
le mot sobriété on écoute tout de suite
la première ministre Elisabeth borde
face au MEDEF
chaque entreprise doit se mobiliser et
agir
j'appelle donc chacune à établir en
septembre son propre plan de sobriété
si nous agissons collectivement nous
pouvons surmonter ce risque de pénurie
mais si chacun ne prend pas sa part ou
que toutes les hypothèses défavorables
se conjuguaient nous serions amenés à
imposer des baisses de consommation
si nous devions en arriver au
rationnement les entreprises seraient
les premières touchées
sobriété Mathieu votre analyse c'est le
corollaire de la fin de l'abondance
bienvenue dans l'ère de la sobriété
tempérance modération frugalité c'est un
mot qui vient du latin on voit bien
l'idée c'est franchement pas marrant la
sobriété c'est un peu Sam le capitaine
de soirée ça fait rêver personne mais
c'est quasiment devenu une injonction
morale ou religieuse ne pas être sobre
c'est quasiment péché dans le débat
public c'est un mot qui est né à gauche
je faisais écolos et les insoumis je
parle dans la sphère politique et qui
aujourd'hui reprit en cœur vient de voir
par tous les membres du gouvernement y
compris Elisabeth borne même le patron
des patrons devient le centre de la
croissance sobre on revient de loin
parce qu'il y a encore peu de temps les
écologistes étaient raillées par le
président pour leur modèle amis chez la
République en marche dénonçait la
sobriété comme une facilité langagière
les candidats doivent expliquer
clairement aux Français ce qu'ils
mettent derrière ce mot fourre-tout de
sobriété disait Jean-Charles collarois
députérem de l'Isère et référent à
l'époque pour la transition écologique
car en réalité ça implique de profond
changement des contraintes voire des
interdictions concernant le mode de vie
c'est plus facile à dire qu'à faire oui
car c'est très relatif c'est très
subjectif au fond la sobriété en tout
cas dans la sphère politique rouler dans
un 4x4 comme on l'a fait Jean-Luc
Mélenchon à Lille pour la braderie
est-ce que c'est sobre mais il s'est
attirer les fous des internautes alors
c'est pas n'importe quel type c'est un
modèle hybride on répondu c'est supporté
oui ça pèse quand même depuis le mois de
mai jeep ne vend plus de voitures
thermiques classiques diesel ou essence
ce qui est quand même une révolution
pour une marque on voit bien que que
le gouvernement dit que lui il est
éteint la lumière comme éco-geste c'est
peut-être un peu court pour les gens ça
paraît être sobre donc c'est du juste du
bon sens lorsqu'il nous en fait c'est
que le terme sobriétaire remplacé petit
à petit tous les autres termes dans les
discours politiques en cette rentrée à
cause du contexte on en parlait quand
même guerre en Ukraine centrale à
l'arrêt et faute de solution
alternatives on est très en retard dans
les dans les énergies renouvelables du
coup on en est réduit à dépenser moins
au fond la sobriété c'est l'arme du
c'est pas de la transition écologique
c'est encore moins de la bifurcation
éthologique c'est le dernier effort
avant la pénurie le rationnement nous
dit Madame borne c'est gérer la misère
comme dirait l'autre autrefois dans les
années 70 on appelait ça à faire des
économies d'énergie ou la chasse
anti-gaspi dans les années 2020 on est
plutôt à l'air de l'indignation de la
morale du moralisme donc voilà ça a pris
de relais et malheureusement
dans la surveillance sociale on a fait
d'ailleurs récemment le ministère de la
transition écologique a laissé sans
vergogne ses lumières allumées toute la
nuit et donc il vient d'en faire à sa
façon les frais ah oui tiens d'ailleurs
on peut je suis sûr que vous allez me
suivre en régie pour rebondir sur ce que
vient de dire Mathieu il y a une
séquence assez savoureuse proposée par
le confrères de de BFM TV où il suivait
Anne-Marie Ducroux qui est présidente de
l'Association Nationale pour la
protection du CL et de l'environnement
nocturne une petite balade parisienne
qui se termine effectivement sous les
fenêtres du ministère regardez on est au
pied du ministère de la transition
écologique mais on voit quand même des
personnes de lumière tout alignées les
unes au-dessus des autres donc on peut
quand même douter qui est vraiment une
personne dans chacun des bureaux qui
sont encore restés éclairés s'il y a
personne la règle c'est que ça doit être
éteint alors après il reste à savoir
s'il y a véritablement des personnes en
activité mais ce qui me fait douter
c'est que les lumières que l'on voit
sont toutes alignées donc je suppose que
les personnes sont pas alignées dans les
bureaux
de manière aussi exacte j'imagine que
depuis la diffusion de ces images
quelques consignes ont dû être donné
Nicolas godmersion prend un peu de de
distance le Terra Nova le cercle de
réflexion donc si tu me tank vient de
faire 14 propositions pour aller vers
une sobriété collective on est toujours
autour de ce de ce mot dont on parle
maintenant dans ce débat on peut aussi
dire que cette crise c'est une
opportunité pour changer profondément
nos comportements et que d'ailleurs les
mesures prises par le gouvernement
français ou plein de gouvernement nous
masquent un peu cette réalité
du marché actuel et peut-être du marché
futur au-delà de changer notre nos
comportement ça peut être aussi
l'occasion d'organiser notre société
différemment et en préservant des
services mais en consommant moins
d'énergie parce que j'ai écouté votre
chronique effectivement là j'ai envie de
me pendre mais ce qu'on a voulu montrer
c'est que la sobriété c'est pas
forcément ça ça peut être de la chasse
au gaspi mais c'est pas uniquement
l'achat au gaspi et montrer du doigt
c'est peut-être déjà faire comprendre
les modes de consommation par exemple
moi j'entends beaucoup que le risque sur
l'électricité c'est la pointe à 19h ça
c'était vrai il y a 10 ans c'est
toujours un peu vrai aujourd'hui ça les
moins mais on a aussi des problèmes
d'approvisionnement entre 10h et 13h
quand tout le monde arrive au bureau et
que il y a le mode de chauffage il y a
l'éclairage et autres et rien de dire ça
je sais pas si tout le monde le savait
autour de cette table ou ceux qui nous
regardent mais déjà ça fait prendre
conscience que ah oui c'est plutôt dans
ces heures là où on peut où on peut
faire un effort la sobriété c'est pas le
rationnement c'est pas distribuer des
quotas à chacun c'est plutôt voilà
comment est-ce qu'on organise
collectivement en disant que il y a des
énergies fossiles dont on veut se
débarrasser il y a des énergies bas
carbone qui pour le moment sont limitées
et je pense qu'elles seront limitées
dans un certain temps donc comment
est-ce qu'on s'organise collectivement
pour préserver des services mais en
consommant moins je vous donnais un
exemple on fait pas pareil Toulouse en
avion juste par plaisir s'il y avait un
TGV entre Paris et Toulouse et ben on
prendra peut-être ça à un prix abordable
on va peut-être ça plutôt que l'avion et
ça c'est de la sobriété vous mettez en
place un plan un plan vélo dans un
centre urbain dense vous changez vous
permettez vous mettez les remplaces les
infrastructures qui permettent d'être
sobre s'agit sur la qualité de l'air ça
agit sur les sur les factures donc c'est
aussi la sobriété c'est ça c'est comment
est-ce qu'on dessine des espaces de vie
plus souhaitables qui préservent les
services qui induisent des changements
de comportement mais qui nous font
consommer moins et pour le 4x4 bah il y
a quelque chose de très simple qu'on
peut mettre en place c'est tout
simplement une norme au niveau européen
en disant bah les véhicules thermiques
c'est fini en 203 mais en plus de ça il
faut aller vers des véhicules plus
légers comme ça sera plus simple de de
les électrifier et comme ça peut-être
qu'on consommera moins de lithium et de
cobalt et peut-être qu'on déplacera
moins le problème des énergies fossiles
vers les énergies minérales voilà c'est
un peu tout ça la sobriété il faut le
vendre non ce qu'on a fait le pari qu'on
a fait c'est le ventre de manière
souhaitable plutôt que de avec un air
moralisateur en disant vous vous avez
pas éteint votre lumière non on pense
bien compris bon signaux alors je reste
sur cette question de bouclier tarifaire
et je vais vous donner la parole à l'un
et à l'autre sur finalement son impact
sur nos comportements est-ce que c'est
pas un frein à une mutation qui est de
toute façon obligatoire vu l'urgence
environnementale à laquelle on est on
est confronté quelques infos sur ce
bouquet tarifaire sans le bouclier
tarifaire le gaz aurait augmenté de
105,1% depuis le 1er octobre
2021 c'est la Commission de régulation
de l'énergie qui nous donne cette
information et ce bouclier est tarifaire
deuxième chiffre tout de suite il a
coûté déjà à l'état français 24
milliards d'euros
le ministère de l'Économie et du finance
qui nous le dit on va voir tout de suite
avec Steve Jourdain qui doit être juste
derrière rebonsoir Steve on va regarder
ensemble comment nos voisins européens
ont réagi de leur côté face à cette
explosion des prix de l'énergie ils
mettent la main à la poche ils mettent
la main à la poche un peu comme nous on
va regarder en détail ce que propose nos
voisins on commence avec l'Allemagne et
l'Allemagne la banque centrale estime
que l'inflation devrait atteindre 10%
10% d'ici à la fin de l'année c'est une
première un depuis les années 50 en
conséquence le Gouvernement Scholtz a
annoncé hier un grand plan d'aide pour
résister à l'envoler des prix 65
milliards d'euros vont être débloqués
pour vous le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
et pour les entreprises parmi ces
mesures il y a notamment une
augmentation du revenu minimum ou encore
un plafonnement du prix de l'électricité
écoutez le chancelier allemand
il s'agit de 65 milliards d'euros si
l'on fait le total de 95 milliards
d'euros si l'on prend en compte les deux
premiers paquets d'allègement
c'est très important c'est nécessaire et
cela doit contribuer à ce que les
citoyens puissent traverser cette
situation avec nous
même recette on débloque des fonds pour
passer la c'est le cas par exemple en
Belgique ou le gouvernement fédéral à
plafonné la TVA sur le gaz électricité à
6% il a aussi baissé les taxes sur les
produits pétroliers et plafonnés les
billets de train l'objectif c'est de
venir en aide au ménage les plus
précaires en Suède le gouvernement vient
lui au chevet des entreprises
énergétiques fragilisées par la crise 23
milliards d'euros ont été débloqués pour
garantir la survie financière de ces
entreprises des entreprises qui sont
très touchées Thomas par la hausse les
prix de production de l'électricité et
certains pays ont décidé évidemment de
la facture des ménages merci Steve et
puis on a vu évidemment au tout début de
ce débat rappelle de la conférence de
presse d'Emmanuel Macron après
une visio-conférence avec le chancelier
allemand autour de cette idée d'une
contribution des entreprises n'emploie
pas le terme de taxes pour ensuite
redistribuer de l'argent au ménage j'ai
une double question pour vous c'est
inantona peut-être question sur les les
coupures parce que j'ai dit qu'on en
parlerait il nous reste assez peu de
temps dans ce débat mais est-ce qu'on
peut y échapper ou ça voilà peut-être
une réponse rapide là-dessus et puis
ensuite ce que je disais tout à l'heure
c'est à dire que là est-ce qu'on n'est
pas en train avec le bouclier tarifaire
je dis pas que il faut lâcher les prix
mais ne passer à côté d'une pédagogie
autour de notre comportement notre
consommation d'énergie alors sur les
coupures je vous avoue que
[Musique]
tout à l'heure je suis sans doute moins
bien placé qu'à Roanne pour répondre sur
le fait que effectivement on a perdu le
signal prix avec ce bouclier tarifaire
bon effectivement quand on commence à
subventionner les prix de l'énergie
comme on le fait aujourd'hui le consomm
moteur n'a plus le vrai prix c'est à
dire qu'il a un prix subventionné et
donc il ne va plus modifier son
comportement en fonction du prix et donc
ce signal prix n'existe plus et par
conséquent il ne modifie pas son
comportement ça c'est effectivement un
problème alors les économistes sont
relevé en même temps il faut quand même
montrer qu'on était dans l'urgence comme
on disait les prix du gaz aurait de
toute façon explosé donc l'équation pour
le gouvernement à mon avis était très
complexe et je pense que le choix du
bouclier tarifaire n'est pas un mauvais
choix au sens où il permet justement
d'avoir une inflation assez basse et on
voit que le différentiel d'inflation
avec un pays comme l'Allemagne justement
entre la France et l'Allemagne
s'explique entre par ce bouclier tarif
et les deux points de différentiel
d'inflation donc ça c'est plutôt une
bonne chose par contre c'est une mesure
qui ne peut pas durer ad vitam æternam
parce que effectivement elle nous coûte
cher donc un moment donné il va falloir
revenir au vrai prix alors les
économistes pensaient à des systèmes qui
consistait par exemple à avoir une
consommation entre guillemets
incompressible sur laquelle on aurait eu
un prix régulé et ensuite laisser le
prix libre disons sur le marché pour les
gens qui veulent acheter plus mais c'est
quand même très compliqué à mettre en
place donc je comprends qu'on est fait
le choix de la simplicité mais encore
une fois ce qui est complexe c'est qu'on
ne peut pas ad vitam eternam avoir ses
mesures je me permets juste de revenir
sur Oui sur le point de la sobriété moi
je pense que c'est très bien d'avoir des
réflexions sur la sobriété j'ai juste
peur que dans l'esprit de certains
dirigeants publics à ce ça fasse un peu
écho à l'idée de décroissance et à
l'idée qu'il faut consommer toujours
moins etc moi je suis quand même partie
zen de l'innovation de la croissance par
l'innovation et je pense qu'on sortira
justement de la crise énergétique grâce
à l'innovation et au fait que
effectivement c'est en investissant dans
les technologies vertes dans les
nouvelles technologies qu'on s'en
sortira et non pas comme le pense
certain avec
Minou reste deux minutes et je voudrais
vraiment qu'on parle des des coupures
alors c'est un mot que là aussi c'est un
peu de sémantique on l'entend pas trop
dans la bouche des des de l'exécutif on
parle plutôt de délestage c'est ça
mais on l'entend de temps en temps il y
a eu un moment des éléments de langage
de la part du gouvernement qui disait il
faut faire le choix la sobriété choisie
plutôt que des coupures subies donc
voilà c'était on associer les deux pour
faire encore un petit peu peur alors
vous me posez vous me demandez s'il va y
avoir des coupures dans l'électricité
en tout cas c'est c'est ça fait partie
du plan d'urgence c'est délestage
tournant c'est-à-dire alors attention
c'est pas des blackout c'est pas un
effondrement du réseau justement pour ne
jamais en arriver là on peut procéder en
dernier en dernière étape à des coupures
tournantes de de ville de départements
éventuellement en plus de deux heures à
10h avec les hôpitaux les écoles etc qui
sont protégés ça peut arriver RTE m'a
dit que ça n'était jamais arrivé de
façon programmée depuis au moins 40 ans
et dans le gaz vous avez là aussi des
des entreprises qui se sont qui se sont
fait connaître et qui ont mis qui ont
établi un contrat avec les gestionnaires
de réseaux ça existe aussi dans le
l'électricité pour être coupé mais elles
sont prévenues
et elles sont rémunérées pour cela pour
être coupés justement pour éviter un
dernier point en fait sans doute sur le
réseau enfin sur sur ce risque de
coupure c'est pas forcément le
gestionnaire du réseau qui va couper qui
va jouer ce sont les prix il y a déjà
des entreprises des industriels qui
aujourd'hui disent on ne va pas je pense
par exemple à ce cometal on ne va pas
produire 3 semaines en novembre 3
semaines en décembre parce que ça nous
coûtera plus cher de produire et donc ça
les coupures et ça va poser une autre
question d'un chômage partiel qui va
peut-être falloir mettre en place dans
ces entreprises
le débat est terminé pardon mais c'est
voilà il y aura un peu de frustration
mais ça prouve qu'il était intéressant
merci à tous d'y avoir participé je
rappelle le titre de votre livre et
robinisé nucléaire une catastrophe
française publiée aux éditions Fayard un
grand merci à toutes les équipes de
Public Sénat c'est un bonheur de
reprendre cette saison à vos côtés la
saison 2 de sens public votre prochain
rendez-vous politique que je vois son
visage qui s'affiche sur nos écrans
Alexis Corbière débuter elle est fit de
la Seine-Saint-Denis président du groupe
RFI à l'assemblée qui sera à l'invité
Dorian Mancini bonjour chez vous bonne
soirée